some scary news last night regarding
washington football team head coach ron
rivera
he has
cancer
it initially came out in a way that
created the impression that it's far
worse than it is it's still cancer
squamous cell carcinoma located in a
lymph node and detected from a self-care
check early stages considered very
treatable and curable good prognosis for
coach rivera for a full recovery
and that's good and it underscores the
importance of always checking always
looking if anything seems unusual on
your skin if you feel a lump somewhere
if you just don't feel right get to a
doctor and have them check you out
because it isn't going to just go away
and that doesn't make you a
hypochondriac right
if you have something and you know
viscerally that it's not right and no
matter how busy you are and there aren't
many people more busy than college or
head football coaches in the nfl or
college level this time of year take the
time to get checked and i guess one of
the benefits of coaching a football team
is there's doctors everywhere so it's
not like you have to make an appointment
and wait to get in you can get the doc
to take a look at this thing that you're
worried about and maybe that is the
thing that gets you the attention but
either way whoever you are wherever you
are the message from ron rivera i think
and the good that always comes out of
something like this
is
it
it tells all of us don't delay because
the sooner you catch something like this
shireen the greater the chance that
you're going to get it treated you're
going to get recovered and you're going
to be fine sooner rather than later
yeah i went to the skin doctor earlier
this week mike and and you need to go to
see a dermatologist whether you think
you have something or not get a check at
least once a year it's invaluable i've
had skin cancer i had mohs surgery and i
don't know what
it's going to involve for ron rivera
that is one of the it's the second most
common skin cancer that he has and mohs
surgery is one of the kinds of things
that they do treatments that they they
do on those sometimes i don't know what
his treatment is or what it entails it
sounds like it's a little more involved
in that but these things are curable and
they're treatable if you get go to the
dermatologist and get them treated you
can't leave it untreated or it is going
to spread and it is going to become
dangerous and possibly deadly and and so
it's great that he got that lymph node
checked out it is in the lymph node that
the skin cancer is but uh it is early it
is treatable and he's going to continue
to coach and and uh probably
be just fine this year coaching i i
would think so
good for ron rivera that he's getting
this taken care of and and uh it's it
everybody else needs to do that too if
they think they have something or
whether they do or not just get to the
dermatologist
hey quick quick story just to underscore
the point i go to the dermatologist
twice a year now because i had my oh
crap moment about 14 months ago doctor's
just doing the routine check looking at
the back we're talking everything's fine
all of a sudden he stops talking
and then and i'm like
doc he's still there yeah yeah and uh
you know oh well you've got it you know
i can't remember the exact medical term
but a suspicious mold
and uh now yeah there's a chance it
could be melanoma
uh we need to do a little biopsy and
take a look at it it's like well i mean
what's the chance so i'm 80 sure it's
not it's like boy i'd really like better
odds than that so you know you spend the
four or five days sweating it out
waiting for the word that it's not
melanoma which really gets your
attention causes you to start doing
research about melanoma and how it
metastasizes and all the fun things
associated with it and it makes you once
you get the all clear which i did it
yeah twice a year i go and and it's of
all the things the diagnostic things
that you can endure
as an adult on the wrong side of 40 or
on the wrong side of 50 in our case
shireen sorry um but we but we're the
same age but um anyway i know i'm not
supposed to talk about that but you know
but i've i've already broken the
protocol so what the hell i'm going to
keep going it's important to do the
things that get you checked out and
getting your skin checked entails
nothing it's completely non-invasive
they just look at you and make sure
there's nothing that is suspicious that
needs to be looked at and it's important
to do it and it's good that ron rivera
noticed it on his own and everyone
on the wrong side of 40 should go to the
dermatologist at least once a year and
if you ever spot anything unusual you
definitely should get to the doctor but
back to ron rivera we wish him all the
best he is the kind of guy who will with
the resolve with the strength that he's
shown over the years i'm telling you
i've said this all week long as it
relates to football coaches if football
coaches were running the pandemic the
pandemic would be gone by now because
they're very linear in their thinking
they know where they want to get and
they know how to get there and that's
what they do right they they take the
steps necessary how do i achieve my goal
and there's no ego there's no pride they
do what they have to do to get from
point a to point b
and i feel like we've lost some of that
i don't want to even begin to stray
toward the political third rail my point
is this football coaches know how to get
to where they want to be shireen and i
feel like ron rivera is going to get to
where he needs to be in his fight with
cancer and i feel like if football
coaches were running this pandemic
they'd already have us where we need to
be because they would know what they
need to do to get there and they would
tell us all to do what we have to do to
get there
mike let's go back to the age thing you
know i i think
you know that ron rivera is going to
have a great training
i i'll say nothing further about it
because i respect my elders
i am a few months older than mike that's
what he's getting at by the way
uh yeah they're good they're gonna have
a great plan for ron rivera and he's you
know gone outside to some specialists
there there's a plan inside with the
team doctors and they're consulting with
the specialist outside they're gonna
have a great plan for him he's gonna
follow the plan and as you said mike
it's great for him that he's got all the
care right there the doctors right there
these teams have the greatest doctors uh
in the world working for them i mean you
just look around the league with the
robert anderson's and the james andrews
and the
jim montzas and all those guys are just
great at what they do and and they have
those guys right there uh to help them
through this so he's gonna get through
this it's gonna be fine for him and it's
gonna be fine for washington and uh he's
gonna he's gonna help turn that uh team
around that organization around great
hire for washington i think they're
going to see that long term
and they do have a plan b in the event
that ron rivera would have to step away
for a period of time but you know every
team better have a plan b this year with
covet 19 because there's a chance your
head coach is going to have to step away
even if he's completely healthy if he
tests positive he's going to be out of
commission for several days maybe a game
maybe two so we wish coach rivera all
the best and you know this comes at a
time when that organization is dealing
with plenty of challenges this is just
another one and uh we think that they
will handle it extremely well and again
we risk we wish coach revere all the
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports